hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex legends again
and today we have the second video of
today that's gonna be the customization
of the new character Watson this is
really for the people that haven't been
able to get unto Watson or just kind of
looking forward or just too lazy to
check and I want to go hop right into
rank that completely understand that or
just don't have her yet and maybe want
to decide I completely understand of
course but I won't be showing completely
everything I know it's kind of says like
all customization but I'm gonna be
skipping the quips and the trackers and
the badges the stuff that like majority
of the characters have and the quips are
like super long and there's so many of
them and they're not really a big
deciding factor on the character you can
always check those out yourself and I
don't want to make this video longer
than it has to be but I won't be showing
the executions that she has all the
skins that she has and her poses and
frames as well yeah so definitely let me
know if you guys enjoyed the video by
leaving a like on it and then
subscribing for some more apex legends
content that'd be greatly appreciated
but yeah I'm gonna shut up so you guys
can listen to it with some beats in the
background and let me know what your
favorite skin or frame or pose or
whatever it is in the comments below and
take care guys enjoy season 2
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]